hey everyone I'm Darius I'm Cyrus I'm
Marcus Lucas and we are the door
brothers here with BuzzFeed and we are
going to tell you guys about our first
times our first times I'm sure shake up
in it wants to go first duelist let's go
youngest to oldest first time you went
by or we were in the grocery store yeah
I just hit my head to the wall and
apparently people will like it when we
get hurt so first I'd be checked when
you wake up first I checked if I have
any text messages but then the next app
is part Instagram
oh you check it to see if you got
messages from Lucas don't worry about it
don't worry about it first big fight you
guys gotten halo 2 in our basement we
had 2 X boxes and before school
literally at like 5 a.m. in the morning
we were honestly halo 2 pearl we were
addicted but we only had two controllers
and 2x boxes so I would fight with
Marcus Cyrus will fight with Lucas and
this one time Marcus had one of those
wired controllers it was my turn to play
we had time slots I would play from 4 to
6 he played from 6 to 8 and he went
overtime and I took the controller he
just started like circulating it around
his head and just like did this kind of
like medieval jab with the controller I
don't know yeah done yet first video
challenge you ever did first video
challenge it was quite a dramatic video
was it this is actually kind of hard you
guys got my expression yeah this is your
question why are we answering no hell no
always help each other out I'm just
gonna play it safe and say it first
official cool challenge was the
gymnastics challenge part one there you
go
always a classic that's good first cell
phone you ever owned
Lucas and I shared a phone do you
remember - what
musica yeah blackberry
we're like text different gods we're
like all like barely texted me and Emma
texted you better than my first phone my
mom gave me her hot pink razor and I put
a $100 bill phone case cover over it to
make it look cooler
first memory that comes to mind when it
comes to vine the first vine that I made
was with my brothers and it was on one
of those carts that you carry your
luggage on
I like crash into a pole on him that was
my vine really yeah
what are you trying to go to Diagon
Alley I don't know me so well guys watch
Harry Potter don't miso water turn they
didn't go through man I guess don't how
to mumble I guess I don't know first
celebrity crush Margot Robbie
someone had to say hopefully my
girlfriend uh they get too mad at me
when I get back home but first big
purchase after you became famous I'll
have to say tired 570s my first big
purchase that was actually one of the
biggest purse ever had first print you
thought went too far it was when we put
slime in dairies is caught and it's
caught in at work anymore
I was actually late for school I was
going to college they dumped slime all
over my car went completely viral and we
ended up having to give the car back to
the dealership they lifted up the hood
and all they saw was burnt slime all
over the engine everywhere and that was
my first car so they're always breaking
our cars - right like they duct-taped my
car - and all the most late to work
Double Trouble managed to twins you know
the first thing you noticed and someone
you're interested in I'll say the
personality or the smile just good to
see a smile Lucas
Azumi don't know one more time
first big youtuber you were starstruck
by and how it went
I'm not gonna lie before starting
YouTube I didn't really watch YouTube as
much I would have to say Lucas and
markets because they started first so
Wow thank you yeah I was just I was
still going to college in school and
these kids were killing it on you - I
was at Yelp you guys are famous don't we
weren't there videos - Reitsma yeah
first time you realize you were famous
the first time I realized I was famous
was when I went to the Bahamas and my
brothers I mean we took a trip out there
everyone pretty much recognizes there we
went to a water park and everyone saw us
and I feel like we just would walk two
steps take a picture walk four steps
take a pictures I couldn't walk right
cool feeling but it was cool it was it
was different
it's both time meeting hearing about the
mido before this it was on Instagram I
think you saw these cute boys really oh
the fish and then they're all brothers
so we're like yeah when I make a video
with them and we call them over
there's always a mimic and it was cool
they were there Instagram handle was
literally mini Dober brothers like there
were awesome fans love and support us
from the beginning so really dude let's
just put him in a video thank you so
much and this was lit make sure you got
your tickets at dilbert or com2 come see
us getting lit on stage with you let's
go most let's show you'll ever see make
sure you subscribe to the doorway
brother's channel as well as Lucas and
Marcus subscribe go love you guys love
you love you bye
[Music]